there was a very interesting reflection
that came up for me today and it was
about the idolatry of famous
intellectuals essentially people like
Friedrich Nietzsche and William Blake
Carl Sagan and other luminaries that I
reflect upon when I think about the
human condition these people have become
essentially thinking about it
they are lived myths right they are no
longer biographical people they exist as
living myths they have become stories
they have become their story right my
relationship with Carl Sagan is my
relationship with the ideas of Carl
Sagan and the lived mythology of Carl
Sagan same with William Blake and same
with Friedrich Nietzsche right I quote
him in reverence when I say those that
were seeing dancing were called insane
by those who could not hear the music
Friedrich Nietzsche what a genius right
so again these people become these lived
myths they are no longer well they are
no longer having to contend with the
realities or the trappings of the human
being right they are God's
intellectual gods but I had this
experience we were talking about the
genius of Jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson is a clinical psychologist and
philosopher and author and public
intellectual who has become a living
myth not just not just a myth but a myth
that is still alive as a biographical
human and then reading about the trials
and tribulations that he's facing with
the actual humanity of his life and a
benzo a benzo addiction and dealing with
depression and like real human problems
it's
it's actually hard for us to internalize
that because it chars against there
creates dissonance with is they lived
mythology status that these people have
attained it's very similar to when a
celebrity dies right when a human being
a mortal being has attained living myth
status and then he dies it it violates
all of our ideas about living myths
because living myths are immortal they
have transcended the animal condition
they have transcended mortality and look
I I love movies and so I love the actors
the living gods that star in those
movies and when we see them aging and
when we see them being stricken by
illness it is sort of doubly traumatic
because it deflates the idea that we
have about these people and our
mirroring of them which is also
reassuring existentially right a lived
mythology doesn't die and by assuming
the viewpoint of that lived mythology
and getting close to that lived
mythology maybe he'll sprinkle some of
his fairy dust on me and I won't die
either but then when something happens
holy that's rough and to a certain
extent I think that's why we often tend
to spend more time in communion with
intellectuals or thinkers who are
already dead because then they are not
mmm bounded by the trappings of a real
human life they are mythologies that
have become immortal so when I quote
Nietzsche or Carl Sagan or all these
other people I don't think about the
fact that they all grew old
they all died that they all got cancer
that they all got died from scarlet
fever that there was suffering at the
end of their life I get to just stay in
their insights I get to just stay in
their ideas and that's so much yummier
right to live in the world of ideas and
abstractions and great truths and
archetypal realities realities beyond
deaths right symbolic realms mythopoetic
realms that's where I want to live
that's where we want to live
but life is suffering right hmm maybe
there's a reframe their life includes
suffering but life is also blissful
that's what Jamie wheel told me the
other day he said life is suffering life
is blissful and life is comical because
the comedy is that you have to navigate
between those two realms that we are
mortal and that we are gods and what the
so yeah that's what that's what came up
for me today and you know just
reflecting upon the ways that we cycle
emotionally rely on these people you
know as if they had somehow transcended
the trappings of our existential
condition through their ideas but their
ideas didn't save them you know they
still died they still succumbed to
entropy and that that's just really
hard to contend with that's
really hard to accept that's
just really difficult to assimilate
right that these geniuses
you know these light chasers these
people who well they cracked themselves
open and became vessels right for
something beyond us right they contended
with the unknown and they brought
something back as beautiful dragon
slayers they brought something back to
3d reality to share with us they brought
back something immortal but then they
still died I just don't I can't I just
you know it's just it's hard it's hard
it's hard it's hard but yeah so
just wanted to share that with you guys
you know so much of my relationship with
art so much of my relationship with the
realm of ideas so much of my my my
relationship with radiance shines
through the trees and with the patterns
that align when you listen to beautiful
music you know and when I am caught up
in the aesthetic reverie and the
aesthetic ecstasy of something so much
more beautiful it cracks it open
and I do those things still lift me up
ghost
knows as Jamie wheel calls them those
bliss crucifixions do resurrect me
they do they do and so that's why
sometimes it's so hard to well to
contextualize that to reframe to find
some way of assimilating and integrating
you know those kinds of divinations and
those kinds of reveries that are so
nourishing and so restorative and so
healing and then you know and then fetch
water and chop wood after the ecstasy
the laundry you know yes we are gods and
yes we are worms and yes we are divine
and yes people get sick and die and
I just know that's that's our work
that's the work
but-but-but-but but it doesn't mean that
we have to succumb to some kind of
nodding resignation or fatalism life can
still be lusty right we can still lose
ourselves and play we can still create
magic circles and create moments
of childlike recess where we remember
what we forgot I always go back to that
you know that that's that's that's kind
of that's my bookmark that's my go-to
you know my homeostatic capacity the way
that I get back to Center after I get
slugged sideways and my expectations are
violated and I have an involuntary
slaying of my ego you know somebody
stabs me from the back psycho
emotionally life hits me over the face I
get back up right I mean the wisdom of
rocky it's not my many punches you give
it's how many punches you receive and
you get back up again I mean look there
is wisdom in that idea always back to
Center
never resign ourselves never lose face
you know
yeah yeah I just always backed you know
always back to love and always back to
all and always back to poetry that's
that's me that's me that's my commitment
that's my that's my commitment that's
what I live by and I live thanks for
listening man I I I love to share you
know I come to know what I think through
languaging and sometimes it's nice to
expose oneself it's a reveal oneself and
to face the reality of oneself and to
explore once you expand oneself from the
film altered states but it's a very real
thing so anyway thanks for watching
we're gonna go decompress now good
afternoon good evening and good night